Jack's attitude was I'm on a journey he
wants to find out about Miami wants to
meet the people Nicole hey Jack hello hi
my name is Nicole Hernandez hammer
I just gave a tour of the town of Shore
crest to jet-black
this is high tide this is just high tide
yeah and it's not really a low tide this
is a foot less than last month crazy so
I came out here and I talked to folks
and I asked them what they thought was
causing the problem and a lot of them
thought it was water mains breaking a
but it is indeed sea level rise
just to be clear we're pretty far away
from the beach right now
and yet the tides bring in water out of
the street like this it comes all the
way here through the floor there's a
limestone yeah well this area is
low-lying
it also has a segment that is low income
and that's kind of the area that I'm
interested in working in educating
people in low income communities about
the impacts of sea level rise and
climate change so you're a climate
scientist you grew up here you can see
the writing on the wall what do you tell
people in the community when you when
you try to communicate what's coming
perhaps they don't have a lot of money
to lose mm-hmm but in terms of how much
they're gonna lose they're gonna lose
more than anybody else cuz they could
lose everything with regard to climate
change there is scientific facts and
then there's the heart and the emotion
if you only have one without the other
they're not really effective you need a
combination of the two to really spark
the flames of positive social change hey
I was going Jason yeah I'm Jason how you
doing to meet you I was able to
introduce him to some people in the
neighborhood I think a lot of times we
think that climate change is something
in the future but when we talk to folks
that are dealing with the problems now
it changes the context in which we're
viewing climate change it's gonna do
value to the home eventually
yeah people are gonna come by and see
you then there's no interest in buying a
property like that you're surrounded by
stinky water shells like years of living
dangerously are incredibly important it
helps amplify what I do and it helps
folks
across coastal areas learn about the
issue of tidal flooding sea level rise
and climate change